So I'm child free by choice.
And everyone always says like,
what's your purpose? If you don't have kids,
what's your purpose?
My purpose is getting my nails done,
um, going shopping,
treating myself.
Look at this new bag I just got from Goyard.
Stunning. Um,
this new sweatsuit I got from ALO.
And being sober,
traveling,
I don't know, taking naps.
Have you ever taken a nap?
It's like the funniest thing ever.
It's so nice. I enjoy naps a lot.
So don't say I don't have purpose just cause I don't have kids.
How dare you! Okay,
by all means, if you don't wanna have children,
please don't have them.
Your life still has purpose.
It still has meaning.
Of course, of course.
But I will say that
I do think a lot of people misunderstand
what parenthood is really like.
All of the phases of raising young children are so short lived.
The sleepless nights with newborns,
the trying to potty train toddlers, having to wake up early.
All those things, like,
they go by so quickly because your children grow up like that.
And that's something I always heard,
but I never truly understood how fast it goes
until I became a mom myself.
And when you stop and do the math,
you realize that most parents will spend most of their
parenthood as parents of adult children.
Like, their kids are gonna be grown up
by the time I'm in my mid to late 30s.
My kids are going to be teenagers.
And so even if for whatever reason,
like, it was impossible,
impossible for me to ever get my nails done
or to ever travel to any place ever,
we have literal decades worth of time to take naps
and to do all of the crazy traveling we wanna do and,
you know, like,
just lay around.
We can do that.
If you go ask anybody over the age of 60,
65, like,
do you. Do you have any chances to nap ever?
Do you have any time to, like,
be alone? They're gonna tell you, yes.
They're gonna tell you
they probably have too much time to do those things.
But what a lot of older people miss is youth
and is young people and children
and being around families and that kind of thing.
That is what a lot of people who are older wish they had more of.